foreign
station we never thought we'd feel and
obviously they're going through the same
thing that we are anything they need
from us we're happy to supporting you I
also want to thank everybody that's
given the kind words about my dad do we
have a social media over the news in
person
um it feels like he's touched a lot of
Hearts over the years more than what we
assumed and knew that he had so it's
been really nice and heartwarming to see
the messages and the people come out and
talk about how I was when they were
younger and how he's helped them
um some beautiful comments
um
we just wanted to say a quick thing that
we're still dealing with what's happened
we still haven't took it all in and so
we just wanted to say a few things
um
just like my dad was an avid fisherman
he loved his family
and he also loved his Forest you read
you wrote red